to which intervals could we restrict f
of x is equal to cosine of x minus pi
over 4 so that f of x is invertible and
they show us what cosine of x minus pi
over 4 what it looks like the graph of
it so let's just think about what it
means for a function to be invertible so
a function is a mapping from a set of
elements that we would call the domain
so let me
my pen is a little off today so let's
see if it works okay so this right over
here
is our domain and this over here is our
range
our
range and a function maps from an
element in our domain to an element in
our range that's what a function does
now the inverse of the function maps
from that element in the range to the
element in the domain so that over there
would be f inverse so that's the
direction of the function that's the
direction of f inverse now a function is
not invertible
one of the situations in which a
function is not invertible you could
have a function where two elements of
the domain map to the same element of
the range
so these both of these elements map to
that element of the range but then so
both of these are the function
but then if this is the case it's going
to be you're not going to be able to
create a function that maps the other
way because if you input this into the
inverse function where do you go do you
go to that element of the domain or do
you go to that element right over there
and so one way to think about it is you
need a one-to-one mapping for each
element of each element of the domain
range there's only one element of the
domain that gets you there or another
way to think about it you could try to
draw a horizontal line on the graph of
the function and see if it passes if it
crosses through the function more than
once and you could see that this is
indeed the case for this function right
over here if i did a horizontal line
right over here now why is this the
issue
well this is showing us actually let me
show do a number that's a little bit
easier
to look at
so let's say i drew the horizontal line
right over here now why is this
horizontal line an issue
well it's showing us that just even
where the part the part of the domain
that's being graphed here that there's
several points that map to the same
element of the range they're mapping to
0.5
0.5 if you this this value right over
here when you take when you input f of
that is equal to 0.5
f of this right over here is equal to
0.5 f of this right over here is 0.5
so if you have that if you have multiple
elements of your domain mapping to the
same element of the range then the
function will not be invertible for that
domain
so really what we're going to do is
we're going to try to restrict the
domain so that for that domain if i were
to essentially apply this what i'd call
the horizontal line test i'd only
intersect the function once so let's
look at the or the the graph of the
function once so let's look at these
choices so the first one is an open set
from negative 5 pi over 4
negative 5 pi over 4. so that's pi
that's negative pi and another fourth of
pi so that's i think starting right over
here
going all the way to negative
1 4 pi so that's this
this domain right over here let me do
this in a new color
so that's this and this does not include
this does not include the two endpoints
so here i can still apply the horizontal
line and in that domain i can show that
there's two there's two members of the
domain that are mapping to the same
to the same element in the range
and so if i'm trying to construct the
inverse of that
what would that what would this l which
is like this is negative 0.6 what would
that f inverse of negative 0.6 be would
it be this value here or would it be
this value here so i would rule this one
out
so let's see negative pi to pi
so negative pi to pi i'll do this in
i'll do this in
this color right over here negative pi
to pi this is a fairly so once again
over and this is a close so we're
including the two boundaries we're
including negative pi
and pi
in the domain
but once again over that interval i
could apply my horizontal line here and
notice or actually i could even apply
the original one that i did that i did
in blue and notice there's multiple
elements in the domain that map to say
0.5 so what would f inverse of 0.5 b
you can't construct a function where it
maps only to one element of the domain
so we could rule this one out right as
well
now negative
one-half pi to positive one-half pi
so negative one-half pi so that is
so let me so i'm running out of colors
so negative one-half pi
to positive
one-half pi
this one is interesting if i apply a
horizontal line there there
there so let's see
but if i apply a horizontal line right
over here i do intersect the function
twice so i have
two members of this domain
mapping to the same element of the range
so i could rule that one out as well
and i'm left with one last choice so i'm
hoping this one will work out so one
half pi
says it's an open set so one half pi
right over there to 5 pi over 4
5 pi over 4 so that's pi and another 1
4. so that's right over there
and let's see
this is
if i were to look at the graph here it
seems like it would pass the horizontal
line test at any point here i could make
a horizontal line over that domain
actually let me do it for the whole
domain
so you see that for the whole domain and
i'm only intersecting the function once
so
for every
every element of every element of the
range that we're mapping to there's only
one element in our domain that is
mapping to it it's passing our
horizontal line test so i would check
this one right over there